NYC the Big Apple New York City ever
heard of it gang the boys are gonna be
here Gotham Comedy Club November 9th on
the Isle of Manhattan we're coming back
we're storming the beaches get some
tickets and come see us it's the New
York Comedy Festival our first time in
it you don't want to miss it the show's
gonna sell out also the boys are going
to be in Hartford Connecticut on
December 14th and we're going to go to
Albany New York on December 15th and
then where are we going after that big
man we're gonna be in Syracuse December
16th get those tickets
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage here is
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite communities fantastic girl to
be classy girls are just a big old piece
of trash we got two of them right here
in the studio I'm your host Dave trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here in Aunt Cody's basement yeah
she's feeling fine she's feeling good
sure I saw her reading a book upstairs
really it was a hustler
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table at me that was a good one I
think they had a couple zingers in
before payday you know what I mean he's
the CEO of Ru garbage International
businessman known in many circles yeah
are you going to G2 what's the deal or
g12 you go to that I'm more of a G18
from the standby list a couple of g
strings if I could if I made I think
those guys party over there I would be I
party here and it's probably a big old
[ __ ] fest over there it's like the
Olympics
those dudes get after it
okay give it up for Kevin James Ryan
goddamn we got KJ now let's go let's go
hey gang happy to be here as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube and as you know those numbers
are true to real true the [ __ ] roof
shout out to YouTube use tubes pretty
good we got a shout out to Big Kev for
that uh yeah big cab shout out for
YouTube
um what are you you watching that on
over there on the YouTube
uh everybody on Street raid dude uh and
then hmm let me find my notes we had a
production patreon.com don't be stupid
what are you doing what if the games
you're watching
you can't [ __ ] over there on that
patreon yeah it's cooking go check it
out we're almost I don't like to tune my
own horn I want to get us over the edge
we're almost to twenty thousand dollars
over there on that patreon that's pretty
[ __ ] Bonkers seven million hours of
bonus content you get a lot of [ __ ] I'll
come clean your car if you need me to we
got videos we got bonus episode we got
hard feelings yeah I love it we got a
lot of [ __ ] on there check it out
Cheesesteak egg rolls pound for pound
might be the best one best patreon out
there comedy podcast I'm going
toe-to-one throwing it down except them
Dylan injuries and a couple others
nine other millionaires
but we're having fun over there so check
it out yeah we love it and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good we're all gonna be going
to the menzinger show yeah soon I think
this is already out but maybe sure it
already happened
way to launch it I did not take
mushrooms give it up for Tebow McMuffin
Toby McMullen what's up dudes what up
T-Bone dude uh so I was editing the last
Family episode sure and in Foley's intro
he alludes to [ __ ] and today really
you said you had a spicy relationship
which means now in our world in the
Canon of are you garbage fully bang on
Tony unless we reboot this thing and do
a lot of retcon change the backstory hey
Wikipedia take it easy will you well
it's Wikipedia Star Wars reference
that's where they have all the
information about the Canon of Star Wars
oh Toby got it he knows exactly what I'm
talking about probably his home page
um and yeah it's not all fleshed out you
know what I mean we're still in season
one here also two who knows she's even a
real aunt she could just be a family
friend she's not our Aunt we live with
antutty but she's not our Aunt we I've
established that really sex with her yes
I've seen a couple of videos over on the
Hub where aunts and nephews get going
the one time they were stuck in a hotel
room and with only one bed you do you
really like that no I don't no that was
like the biggest video I would typically
this is not an a what is a family
program but that was like the biggest
video on PornHub in like a year all
right it was like it did like 375
million views what do you what are you
talking what are you typing in I don't
type in anything I stay around that
suggested for you really just you left
the algorithm do the work they got my
number I'll tell you that
poor Mr hubs got me dead the rights
he knows what he's doing talk about an
SEO
Gang This is a family episode I don't
think it is with the [ __ ] what we're
talking about over here gang it's a
family episode we're going to be reading
off your questions as you know when you
sign up for the old patreon there we'll
uh we'll answer we'll ask your questions
on the air now we got a bit of a bit of
a backlog as cage J says but we promise
we're going to get to the mall yeah of
course uh uh and also like we said the
best you get for if you're on patreon
you get first crack at a garbage
question it's just the best way to do it
everybody I mean we get the DMS we get
the emails people [ __ ] knock on my
door hey did you ever think I thought
about it we gotta get to the patreon
because we get a hot one right DM yeah
sure then I pass that off as mine no big
deal
you've you've done that a couple no I
always give credit where credit is due
yeah right
oh yeah we're working on that something
like that yeah yeah I already got one on
my list well that's my go-to answer
anyway for legal if anybody brings up
anything to me yeah it's like SNL
somebody sign away all right somebody
somebody could ask me about like oh yeah
they're putting up a CVS or I don't have
any idea
I was in a movie doing that sure sure
but now of course we always make sure
everybody knows who yeah yeah of course
we're having fun over here big we're
having a good time yeah T-Bones fiddling
with the cam T-Bone y'all right over
there you're freaking me out take the
lens cap off it's happening buttons get
on it did you ever have a uh what like a
an older family member that like would
like tell you to sit down because
they're you're making them nervous when
they when you stand around them no I
don't think I had a couple of uncles and
if they were sitting down you couldn't
like stand over them oh like yeah Sit
Down You're making me sit down you're
making me nervous I would get that uh
yeah but you're breathing heavy I know
they think you're gonna snatch the
[ __ ] Turkey Leg out of there
[Laughter]
you're like a seagull they think you're
gonna swoop in and grab something
and take out an eye floating over the
breakfast no you just spit and it's in
your beard okay I've been doing that
while it's on your hand I saw you wipe
your nose on your hand and on your shirt
I've been doing that a lot man this guy
is boogers
[Applause]
really man for me being such a
germaphobe the fact it's like God's sick
thing the fact that I'm such a
germaphobe and now I'm connected to life
with a germ it's a tough look I'm
starting to get to the point where this
is like this is like immersion therapy
you know what I mean like if you're
afraid of heights they throw you out of
a plane they do that
I'm afraid of germs so I have to have a
podcast with you
um I'm getting to well now we're turning
a corner we got the meal plan coming all
right all that stuff this has been it's
a big Corner you've been trying to turn
for two years I'm gearing up I'm priming
the bums I need cake
[Laughter]
guys fat quartz on patreon it's a
[ __ ] doozy okay anyway I noticed
yesterday when we were having we're
having a nice meal was this fat court
with a good friend of ours no I'm just
gonna say okay I'm aware that I might be
repulsing people with my eating the way
I eat oh thanks for tuning in yeah yeah
I do the napkin I have to be very
careful I like you know sometimes I'll
hold the napkin with a bite it's very
geriatric the way I eat it is but
there's also a speed to it that like
wait it's quicker it's slow it's quick
you I think this is
patreon give them a little sneak peek I
think you you're aware of how fast
you're eating so you slow it down in
mixed company yes because I've done this
I'm aware because I'm just a binding but
I assume there's food on my face yeah
yeah and I feel like I'm grossing out to
other people that's why I wouldn't say
gross out but I would say
you don't make a lot of eye contact me
no I treat it like a bank job dude
no [ __ ] Witnesses head down no eye
contact dropped a gun walk out quick but
not fast yeah um
I was the mutual friend that we had we
had a meal with yesterday I had dinner
with uh-huh he had at one point had
suggested because there was sun-dried
tomatoes in my dish sure and he said are
you like do you like sun-dried tomatoes
I said yeah there's just a lot of them
so I'm pushing them to the side a little
bit and I got the feeling
that he I said if you want one please
help yourself
I don't think that was ever on the table
in my head I'm like man does he not know
what a what a slime ball I am he's gonna
share food with me
because you wouldn't what no
there's no way you would take like if I
took a bite of a hamburger you wouldn't
take a a bite a bite of it no because
that's bad right the two waves okay I
want a little look in the kippy's head
here's a real patreon content as you
hold the burger you bite into it that
half that you bit into is now a no-fly
zone in my book okay say Antarctica yeah
that's like the [ __ ] 87th parallel I
can't cross it was that the right number
something like that yeah I figured you
would know that Johnny Army 82nd maybe
no it's 87th or 89th whatever
um button's gonna google in that way uh
uh I I don't even know what you're
talking about talking about type in 87th
parallel I think it's that yeah it's the
Korean Peninsula I believe you're right
Vietnam no Korea I think it's Korea wow
we look like a couple of [ __ ] commies
over here
hey big red relax
yeah a circle of latitude in north in
the North in the northern hemisphere in
the Arctic Ocean is 187th yep oh so I
pulled it right no you didn't I said
87th parallel is that the one that
divides North Korea and South Korea
though oh gee we couldn't just let Kimmy
win it and move on
I thought I got I thought I gotta have
clean I know it exists I try to deflect
from my slob eating
so that's North Korea right that's done
I can't go I would assume where the
hands make contact with them the hands
are dirtier than the mouth I presume
from what I've seen on a day-to-day
basis over the past decade it's so the
hands aren't good like a Komodo dragon
yeah if I get that on me and then it's
like stuck to your [ __ ] you know it's
like shoots the gak at you
uh but I don't I wouldn't that's with
most people so you you're you know
the lady the lady you'll share right
you'll of course what about you Toby
would you eat off my plate I have yes he
has what have you eaten look at that
place it looks like a [ __ ] wet rat
right now I believe I've used my fork in
your plate as well yeah yeah we're
cheering yeah good luck with the herpes
yeah oh man don't remind me oh no at
that juncture I stayed far the [ __ ] away
yeah when I when I had a screamer down
in Houston there's grass on the field
yeah that was a I caught a burner going
and we talked about it and you used my
napkin and then I used it and I've been
thinking about it every day since and
I'm a scruncher I like a lot of napkins
oh man
oh that's good that's good stuff that's
good stuff right there but the one thing
that you mentioned that it was it was
real trashy like you know one of those
like uh blue collar colloquialisms that
I'm always you know you say I'm always
good for I always got in the hopper to
Catholic School colloquialism no like
same you know what I mean like you know
you can't catch the train if you ride
the bus or whatever
um was my grandfather or anybody the
older people would say what oh okay so I
got old people and eating bugs me out
dude I can't even be in the same [ __ ]
yeah that's a tough one one time we went
to visit my grandmother when I was a kid
real quick at a nursing home and uh we
were in the cafeteria and this old guy
that she was friends with was eating
scrambled eggs nope and something
happened that's gonna ruin my day just
here and something happened and he
started shooting uh scrambled eggs out
of his nose oh I've been there they go
up quick I was there's like no gravity
with those things they operate on their
own I was over easy for the next 10
years
yeah oh my God I remember just being
like I look at vanilla pudding in my
hand too yeah ruin my own sometimes the
teeth pop out a little bit oh my God
bless the old people but you know it can
be an awful all right so go ahead your
grandfather if there was a game on and
you were a kid right like say [ __ ]
Thanksgiving and there's like the
football game on whatever and there's
like bunch of kids running around and
then your wall whatever you get hit with
you'll make a way better door than you
do window yeah you make a way better
daughter hey who's winning the game I
can tell you if I can see it with these
damn kids running around hey pop-up
upgrade the material over here come over
there and slap you around throw you in a
house
[Laughter]
shout out to pop Big Pop
does he pop the Patriot pop and then the
yes my dad's pop too his his dad was
popped now he's pop oh you don't say
yeah and my mom's grandma
or gamma
and they were babies all right stop it
oh knock it off between that and the
scrambled eggs I'm not gonna sleep in
here
I need a chlorine shower man all right
with that being said let's get into some
questions that's what I was gonna say no
that's what I was like let's do that
this is a silly one we're having a good
time having a good old time
um let's see this one's from Jennifer
this was a big one when I was a kid oh
no sorry this is a different one
um this is from Jennifer have you ever
fallen out of a car as a kid because
there was no seat belt that was a thing
that happened with older cars the doors
would just open
remember that that's when they put in
that child safety [ __ ] yeah you would
make a left turn and the kids they would
be that benchy and it would just [ __ ]
right out into the [ __ ] intersection
like the mailman
uh I've almost fallen out yeah and I've
gotten screamed at four too but now I
was messing with the door that those
that's when they came out I remember
they came out with the child locks I
remember looking at my Mom like yo if
you engage these things I'm gonna be
real [ __ ] pissed we trust each other
here what am I in a [ __ ] squad car I
know what the [ __ ] lady yeah it's like
you got me on a b and e you're bringing
me downtown I don't like that at least
crack our window you know what else I
don't like why I hate the child window
in the back yeah I gotta get my elbow
out sure there's they should be and be
able to engage that disengage what all
the way down yeah
[ __ ] out of here with that yeah yeah
yeah man
um it's brutal when you're back there
you feel like an idiot I don't like how
my windows have I think you feel like an
idiot most times but that's just me I
don't like when my window's half down I
feel like if I get into an accident
that's it that's gonna hurt you even
more it's gonna slice your face off I
like it all the way up or all the way
down no in between
I mean you're cuckoo bananas doesn't
that make sense though what is the
difference between all the way up and
halfway down well you're still getting a
face full of glass yeah it's breaking
it's not gonna [ __ ] it's not gonna
come out at one piece in [ __ ]
denoginize you like Fifth Dimension or
whatever
yeah I I just feel like it it could hit
you sure I guess cut my jugular yeah and
it's over uh I don't know if I've ever
mentioned this but pulling into uh
Wildwood New Jersey where I frequented
it as a child there was a wooden bridge
I'm gonna try to throw you over it there
was a wooden bridge uh-huh and it was
like there was pieces it well I would
love to see it now as an adult to see
how structurally sound it was but as a
[ __ ] six-year-old kid and then my dad
would tease me because he's a real nice
guy you know this could just get a
little anxiety before his week off yeah
it would be [ __ ] night time we'd be
pulling in on a Friday and we'd be like
Dad let us know when we're getting to
the bridge we'd be like panicked if this
thing's gonna collapse he'd be like roll
the windows down in case it collapses we
can swim out that's what he would tell
us yeah
we're out due to like a [ __ ]
six-year-old a seven year old but that's
true you have to I know but it was an
accident you might not be able to get
the window down with the pressure that's
dude I learned that at five years old on
my way to the [ __ ] Ferris wheel I was
[ __ ] schmitzing the water was a fat
little kid I was eating my feelings two
more slices of Sam's please this might
be my last meal I think I've told you my
dad taught me something like that when I
was real young too young
um when he would turn all the lights off
in the house and turn the lights on
outside and we would just sit and look
out the window yeah and he said when the
lights are out they can see it yeah when
you can't see it when the lights are out
there they can't see you
a couple of trip wires out front that
was right around the same time we
switched him over to decaf
um
dad's digging bungee stick bits no more
Diet Coke in the 18 for you
trying to get my TV dinner on
but how how scary would it be what
because that water thing is the kind of
thing where you have to wait till it
fills up it has to fill up completely
before you can swim out yeah plus you're
for sure gonna drown because you're
gonna open the door and be like ah Jesus
and then sucking a bunch of water yeah
also unless you're in a convertible
you're [ __ ]
I mean let's call this pay to Spade here
I never liked to I never like a coop
getting in the back seat pulling the
seat back and getting back there that
was a death trap yeah oh that was my
worst fear yeah having a kick out that
back window to get out oh you that's
great I mean yeah I mean your anxiety
runs at another level
it's cooking talking about true to roof
it ain't no patreon I'll tell you that
much
um this is in the same realm this is
from Michelle this is my first question
did you ever have to duck down in a
pickup truck because you didn't have
enough seat belts for everyone
that was a big or even any car yeah back
in the day you would lap it like if you
were coming home from soccer practice
say like say my dad was taking home like
the friends kids hey well you know we'll
all go here whatever take them back to
my house there might be like seven eight
nine kids in a [ __ ] Jeep sure laptop
and then there would be like oh there's
a cop he [ __ ] hit the deck yeah make
sure no you don't get [ __ ] wrapped up
we used to lay down in the back of a
truck back of a pickup we did that yeah
when it became uh
uh frowned upon to do that yeah some
areas you can't Hawaii they're big on
that they're always in the back of the
trucks I told you I did it in the
Dominican Republic probably nice
cruising around a real nice tropical air
and an aircraft gun
a man and the big guy taking out migs
left and right
um
but I think I might have said this as a
kid I had my dad we had like my dad had
a work truck and it was on the weekend
we were doing something and me and my
two buddies I was like yeah we'll
[ __ ] ride in the back of it like he
was like running errands and we were
just [ __ ] cruising around in the back
of it and then a kid went home and told
his mom hey I was right in the back of a
pickup truck and I was he was in a lot
he was never allowed back over my house
really yeah which I get do you think the
mom called your parents uh I think that
happened yeah it was always the worst
yeah also yeah his mom was a little bit
of a stickler for the rules yeah my dad
tend to look the other way on a lot of
things broad was up tight yeah I don't
want to sound he might he might be a
listener he still likes some posts from
time
but I get it I mean now if I was a kid I
wouldn't want my kid in the back of a
pickup truck I wouldn't do any of that
[ __ ] what do you mean they were smoking
we turned out pretty well though what
well one of us falling apart over here
yeah
um that the charred meat the [ __ ]
whole nine yards yeah I like it crispy
charcoal hot dog good night let's talk
about the daily tip my friend presented
by bet MGM that's right talking about
the big dogs there if you're new to
betting if you're a seasoned veteran
however you like to do your uh you're
betting when you're betting on sports
it's best to be in the know and if you
listen to The Daily tip you will be yeah
they got uh the best betting analysis
and information and it's a pretty good
show too right they got a guitar good
riffing the hosts are great the host
Michael Jackson Michael Jenkins and
Chelsea messenger break down the big
takeaways and make sure you know
everything you need to bet smarter uh
with feature guests like bookmakers
audacity insiders and bed MGM experts
you've always got a fresh take on the
action as you know if you're a bet and I
used to I started betting in college
high schools you know but you know just
kids got the fever things are always
changing and you just need info right
you need up-to-date info what's
happening you need to take quarterback
this kicker that trade here trade there
you just need info information is power
when it comes to this kind of stuff
that's right so as much as fun as it is
to bet on the game it's even more fun
when you've got the inside scoop there
you go ready to bet with an edge tune
into the daily tip right presented by
bet MGM listen weekday 6 a.m to 9 A.M
Eastern on Audacity Spotify or your
favorite podcast app one more time guys
a daily tip presented by bet MGM listen
weekdays 6 a.m to 9 A.M Eastern on
Audacity Spotify and your favorite
podcast app do it yeah give me how about
that all form all form got a brand new
couch sit in the studio it's
unbelievable folks over there at Helix
got into the couch game yeah I love
their mattresses now that donut couches
T-Bones take a little snooze on it right
now I'm looking at them it's fantastic
drifting off into Dreamland all right
they were cool enough to send us one uh
we needed a new couch for for tooties
anyway we did perfect and I got a pretty
hard to set up I did it all by myself
and I'm not even messing around less
than an hour 25 minutes or something
crazy it all pieces together it's like
you know it's like a model it's like
boom boom boom boom you screw it in real
quick it's not a two-man job one guy can
do it I did it and I'm Bozo as you know
uh I will back him up on that he is a
bozo what makes it really cool is for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional storage you go on you pick
the color you want the shape you want
the size you want the legs you want the
whole nine yards they do it uh also if
it's delivered directly to your home
with a fast free shipping uh right now
if you buy a sofa from a traditional
retailer it'll take months to arrive
that's Jam my sister up she went to get
a new couch they're totally like 18
months oh yeah that's ridiculous yeah my
mom got caught up in the same thing yeah
that thing was here and like like it
felt like two hours I know it was like I
hit enter and then if the guy was
knocking on the door it really was it
really did come quick uh yeah so if
getting the sofas uh trying it in store
sounds a little too risky you don't need
to worry you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep it or not you
know These Guys these companies are top
notch
um and if you don't love it they'll pick
it up for free and give you a full
refund nice
um let's see uh to find the perfect
silver for you check out all forms.com
garbage and all formers this is this is
the thing baby all formers offering 20
off all orders for our listeners at all
forum.com garbage one more time 20 off
your order for our listeners at
allform.com garbage do it yeah
um this is a very [ __ ] car episode
this one's from Chris Scott ever use a
leaf blower to clean out your car
[ __ ] hey really oh it's the best what
they do it at the uh at the car wash oh
they blow out this dude it's awesome and
my brother has a pretty sick blower he's
got like a still I bet he does
I guess still you know the Stills s-t-i
steel steel yeah he's got one of those
things comes you couldn't put that
together that it's steel
this is a great company it's real strong
it's called still
anyway yeah when I when that thing's in
the garage and I go home blast it all
out really oh I never thought of that
great you just gotta open the doors on
the other side and blow it out
take the rugs out through the rugs
[ __ ] noise you know what I associate
steel with one of the greatest programs
of all times the great outdoor games the
where the Lumberjacks compete oh yeah
you've seen that you've had chat on
ESPN2 on like a Friday afternoon or
something
yeah I thought I'd be pretty good at
that yeah yeah you know thought about it
I've ever worked a chainsaw but I don't
know how they get three people at those
things but they're packed what I don't
know how they get three people yeah I
mean there's like 5 000 people watching
guys [ __ ] cut down a tree think about
the rural aspects of the [ __ ] I would
go watch it for sure really yeah a
couple of beers
somebody line us up with some dicks you
remember well you know what else other
in that same world what other show was
really good that lager show extreme
loggers or Alaskan lagers or whatever
where they would [ __ ] hook them up
and [ __ ] drag them up the hill oh
yeah those guys would get manium that's
always nice
did they talk about a denoginizer
that'll [ __ ] Lop you right off
Friday at seven welcome back to Maine
getting maimed
oh that was a scary concept when you
were a kid you'll get me yeah oh that
was screamed at me a couple of times
that dramatic fever my mom would throw
at me
I think it was romantic
yo Gabriel catch-ramatic fever how old
are you that's what I was saying a
better chance of getting scabies
third grade with TB
dramatic fever dramatic or new it's not
can't be pneumatic I'm having trouble
remembering it I think it's rheumatic
fever oh she worked in a hospital she
was in the medical field oh yeah janitor
but still it's rheumatic fever it's a
disease that can result from it
adequately treated strep throat
reasonable I like strep throat all the
time scarlet fever yeah I don't know
what that is
that means you're a [ __ ]
and then Mark me with an S shout out to
The Scarlet Letter
um well yeah two things I never
understood hit me but more than that
for our purposes here today one of them
being Euros now I got that all figured
out
um uh pneumonia and walking pneumonia
yeah what's that all about I think
walking pneumonia means you can walk
around they're okay uh
uh T-Bones on it because pneumonia is
fluid in your lungs is it yeah
that's all it is it's fluid and not all
it is but it's fluid in your lungs and I
guess walking pneumonia is probably an
abbreviated version of that it's just
milder symptoms of pneumonias okay
walking pneumonia sounds worse
to me like it's walking all over you
that's how you take it honestly yeah so
he's beating the [ __ ] out
I walk in the Muzz walking and walking
all over me yeah no yeah walking
pneumonia is uh yeah less severe fever
that's what she would because that would
get strep throat every year why
monsters you're smoking yeah smoking
Bernie's at seven uh
my tonsils were doc had me switch over
to lights for a couple of months
hey I know you're not it's not as cool
but hit the ultra lights for the summer
will you uh yeah we're getting every I
would get it the same week every year it
would be like [ __ ] though after like
the first week of March strep wasn't
that bad once you got over the initial
Panic of seeing those white things in
the backyard that swallowing for two
days or you couldn't even like ice pops
yeah but that was that was my ticket to
unlimited ice box you would wake up at
like three in the morning your mouth be
all dry it's like to talk about wanting
to be no organized I would have taken if
they would have been like well cut your
[ __ ] Drake out I would do it really
and you're in so much pain every swallow
was like a [ __ ] you had to think
about and then I could do it I could do
a little strep throat you're what yeah a
little ginger ale on the couch you can
have that one I mean you probably do
that most days anyway yeah but it's
better when you're a little kid and
you're sick and your mom does all that
[ __ ] for you to run so the stock and get
some ice pops that and was big was off
the paper if you were out of school like
if we if I was like hey you're gonna
stay home right my mom would whatever
get me situated on the couch oh then go
run and get two movies
head up there to Blockbuster or epic
videos let's grab some wings hit that
back room too see if there's any aunts
and uncles going at it when you guys
were kids and sick did you have like a a
standard set of movies you like to watch
on sick days uh I mean price was right
was always a [ __ ] yeah he had to do
the Price Is Right I was a big Kelly
Ripa guy so I would do Regis and Kelly
big fan of Kelly
bang you were watching daytime TV yeah
Rosie O'Donnell showings are yapping
about on The View you know uh Regis
Regis is a born Entertainer and that she
was eye candy I was more of a Regis and
Kathy Lee man you're an older guy that's
right that's when it was done right
Gelman ran the show Gelman still ran the
show probably still does
um
Rosie O'Donnell show had a nice program
at 10 o'clock I believe it was she did
yeah yeah that was more TV there was no
offer of movies my mom would go every
now if she wasn't if she was I guess at
that point she was working nights or
like like you know second shift or
whatever so she would go get you know
I'd be like hey get whatever and
whatever or something like two cops
unless you get something like [ __ ]
Adam Sandler or [ __ ] you know David
Spade or something I could squeeze some
ice pops out of Patty and I could
squeeze some crane apple or crane grape
out of her that was usually about as far
as it went
why what would you watch Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles 2 secret of the use oh
that of course anything I had on Deck
was big oh the VHS I'm talking yeah you
only had like yeah but like we probably
we never had that collection we had like
a handful of things that like
we you know we never returned to
Blockbuster oh dude I've seen Ferris
Bueller's Day Off about 97 times wait
you had actual like movies like that we
didn't really have movies like unless
unless we taped it no that we never did
that oh yeah we were bigger I don't know
you got to like work for NASA to
understand that they're right there we
no I know you jerked off to the one
seven thousand times Police Academy do
you want to hear that Patty while you
were out there hard working this guy is
at home talking his little route
experiments
yeah those movies right there we've had
those since 19 I don't know [ __ ] 85
whenever we got our first VCR yeah that
was that's I get it but yeah no we at
least had a handful of movies that you
got in something well my mom did is she
signed up for HBO for like a month taped
a bunch of [ __ ] and then and then
canceled it yeah they're all they're all
original HBO uh tapings every single VHS
like that growing up would open with the
HBO yeah going again going down the
street yeah old one [ __ ] sweet that's
so trashy
that's [ __ ] interesting tight title
card though I'll tell you that
wow your mom was a bootlegger
that's crazy your mama's bootlegging
films
moving a couple down at the hair salon
huh holy [ __ ] she's leaning in I got
lialaya
you seen Tommy Boy
holy [ __ ] dude yeah science talk about
slanging them out the trunk that in the
last email was doing it that that in the
last episode of mash went around my
family she had that taped we wore that
thing out she's a big Alan Alda fan a
little too big
someone said you're a little too big
uh wow yeah that's crazy no I never did
that we just had a handful of them yeah
unnecessary roughness was a big one
remember that I was 10 years I was in
college when I came out okay I'm asking
if you remembered I didn't ask [ __ ]
how old I remember the film okay is that
with Keanu no that was the replacement
unnecessary roughness was with them
who's the quarterback it was the old guy
he had two years of Eligibility so he
went back and played
T-Bone you on that buttons has he Bert
Lancaster
he wasn't the oldest [ __ ] Scott Bakula
got back what yeah no way yeah Chachi
yeah and the uh shut up and Sinbad yeah
Sinbad was the coach I think uh it was a
female kicker and she was a type that
was the replacement shabozo
which one's Joey Coco Diaz in the
replacement no that's the longest yard
you stink what do you mean you're
combining who was the coach Al Pacino
you're just combining every football
movie from the last 20. the charger
Blitz
you run from a pass
you charge a rush you run from a pass
what do you think unnecessary roughness
rating on Rotten Tomatoes in my house it
was about a ten thousand yeah [ __ ]
Rotten Tomatoes what is that [ __ ]
33. that's pretty good they don't
[ __ ] know what they're talking about
but what's the fan rating or is that 46
fam right come on 50 that's pretty good
that's a coin flip not bad yeah that was
a good piece of business
um
flip the coin piece of [ __ ] or Modern
Glass
yeah I mean come on what were you doing
here
let's see I don't Jive or Rotten
Tomatoes anymore they went corporate
didn't they didn't somebody [ __ ] them
who scooped them up I don't work for
that T-Mobile or something probably one
of the posts but it's also like
everything that gets like the [ __ ]
listen this is a very uh but [ __ ] a
Critic a movie I don't get that oh
Warner Brothers bought it
back on board you boys are in the if you
guys are in the market for a podcast
what a boom in patreon I'm [ __ ] Jamie
on a spot over here today with the goose
it's pretty good
uh
um
all right this one's [ __ ] home run
for Miguel Del Torre ever take your
shirt off before a fight
you were guaranteed to get your ass
kicked man that kid always got that was
always a one and done that guy that kid
went down like a bag of dirt
[Laughter]
oh that's something with pulling up your
pants
talk about a [ __ ] uh I see a knockout
coming as soon as someone does that
pulling up their yeah this thing he puts
their hands real high like this you're
getting [ __ ] the [ __ ] Irish guy
you're about to get tuned up on them oh
man that's [ __ ] great
holy [ __ ] that's always a sign of a guy
who's like let me let me try to scare
him now listen if my shirt came off in
the middle dude if somebody even like
you know my I would tuck my shirt in to
make sure it wasn't coming that was a
tough look too when they rip your shirt
yeah your titties are flopping around
it's like spring break
it's like it's like hippy's going wild
over there yeah I I didn't I didn't have
the uh I didn't have the rip shirt body
that wasn't really Fabio I'd wear a
jumpsuit if it was a scheduled fight but
I remember two girls got into a fight I
was a freshman and two girls both pretty
hot got into a fight they were like a
Junior and senior got into a fight in
the hallway and both of their shirts got
ripped and it was literally just two
bras going at it God damn that'll change
a 16 year old's life yeah man I got that
that on Loop for a little while yeah
yeah yeah I was always playing in the
background
like a baseball game holy [ __ ] yikes
spicy
uh first time I ever saw a lace bra
I don't even know what that is I'm not
sure what lace is I gotta be honest with
you oh my god listen we're all friends
here
I'm gonna shoot you straight the old
lady keeps a traditionalist
what's lace like the lace you know the
little yeah describe to Define it with
the word that I don't understand I think
I know but I've never been like ooh all
right let's see if I can let's see if I
can I know what I could if I showed me a
bra and a lace bra be able to pick it up
okay it's ready I'll see if I can Define
it you pull it up
sure you have it up everybody looking
for a definition yeah yeah I know what
lace is okay hold on all right I'll tell
you okay give me one second
delicate okay soft
it has little holes in it so you can
kind of see a little nippy
and it has like flowers on it
you've I don't think you got one word
right out of the proper definition I'm
not even [ __ ] around
a fine open fabric typically with one
cotton or silk made by looping twisting
or knitting thread and patterns
specifically used for trimming garments
oh man I'm taking a look at these bad
boys my lady's got a couple
and he ain't too shady
shout out to the lace family
[Laughter]
keeping kids hard
[Laughter]
Kip let's talk about that box of awesome
episode
bespoke post you got me right there and
let me tell you something they are
awesome yeah all right the Falls here
okay if you like cool stuff get yourself
a box of Awesome from bespoke post it
could be grooming materials it could be
outdoor barbecue stuff it could just be
outdoor stuff pocket knives hammocks
it's almost too close too you keep
telling me that I forget you keep
forgetting that they're doing clothes as
well uh-huh and coolest part about them
is they partner with small businesses
emerging brands that bring you the most
unique Goods every month that's what I
like yeah it's like you know it's it's
Boutique yeah it's Boutique it's well
made handcrafted cool nice [ __ ] cool guy
[ __ ] it's good to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com your answers
are going to help them pick the right
box of awesome for you as we've always
said new boxes come out every month tons
of different categories whatever you're
into you can find something you want
travel gear whatever you want it's free
to sign up you can skip a month at any
time if you want one month we've got to
take a month off do it again in two
months easy peasy sure each box only
costs 45 bucks and has a total of
seventy dollars worth of gear in it free
money baby a lot of money nice uh plus
with each box of awesome like we said
you're supporting small business ninety
percent of everything that comes in your
box of Awesomeness from a small up and
coming brand here's the deal you get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up for box of awesome.com and enter the
promo code garbage at checkout that's
box of awesome.com code garbage for 20
off your first box do it
oh let's talk about mint mobile room
mobile yeah mobile the guys who are
turning it upside down by passing the
savings on to you because what happens
when you sign up for a big contract
mobile number Mobile phone y'all jammed
up fees overages contracts and this and
that next thing you know they got you
over a barrel mint mobile goes right to
you they pass the savings on to you now
I've been told I don't know if it's true
it can't be true I earned 15 a month 15
bucks a month
bunkers you get unlimited talk text
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network that's mint
mobile baby it's the same thing you're
getting the other big guys are offering
you're getting it for 15 bucks 15 clams
a month I've always said this my wife
uses it been using it for years that's a
pack of Bernies
you ain't lying uh my wife uses it and
it she never signed a contract she used
this temporarily and now it's the go-to
thing because you never you never know
anything else so if your contract's up
you're looking at a second line whatever
you're doing if you're in the market for
a new cell phone plan check out mint
mobile have you covered seven day money
back guarantee uh to get your new
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shifted to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com garbage
that's mintmobile.com garbage cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
midmobile.com garbage now back to the
show when was your last official
childhood fight do you remember what's
childhood just a little keep it strict
I'm not talking about college or after
college uh that's when they got that's
when they got up so they got a little
dangerous yeah uh child
I fought a kid the other day yeah I
fought a nine-year-old really cleaned
them up Jerry noraski keep his [ __ ]
mouth shut I've been beefing with some
kickball kids we would we were a little
[ __ ] wonky as and we would fight each
other most times most scuffles were
friends me and my brother fought every
like physically fist fought every single
day one summer yeah every day yeah it
was insane yeah that was I mean me and
my boys would get drunk and then
somebody would say something whatever
then you would [ __ ] end up in a
tussle like a it was probably junior
high before and then college and early
20s
there was a few fights but my last
childhood like childhood childhood fight
was in seventh grade
uh this kid I think Dan Brown or Dave
Brown beat the [ __ ] out of me yeah and I
deserved it 100 oh I no I'm sure you did
it was one of those old school ones
where he was like a good guy I was
running my mouth or something like that
and I thought I could take him and I
went in real quick and next thing I know
he's on top of me he's like half the
size of me he's on top and he had a cast
on his right hand because he had broken
I got hit by a cast dude he was just
[ __ ] wailing on me yeah I thought my
face was gonna fall off and he hit me
like four or five times and stopped and
he's like are you done and I was like
yeah yeah and then he put out his hand
and he and he held me up and we were
buddy we were buddies from there on out
yeah I mean you were his [ __ ]
I had to pull my pockets yeah right hey
bunny ears let's go
put a little Kool-Aid powder on my lips
I like your skirt up put something lace
on I wanted to ask you this too I'm here
for it big guys because it happened to
me yesterday have you ever been putting
on your underwear and both legs go in
one hole but yeah but you still pull
them up just uh whatever I don't think I
got them all the way up no yeah I feel
sexy
wait you just yanked him all the way up
just a seat just a c yeah you ever do
that [ __ ] no yeah I don't think I've
ever done it on purpose I feel like I'm
feeling a little mini skirt I feel like
it I feel like it happened hey I get out
how did they recover from that there's
no way they snap back into place after
Rocket Man I did I got my Good Fellas
they're good good fellow okay godfellow
whatever my underwear how would I you
looked at me like I was going to confirm
the brand of your Underoos we talked
about it the ones I get from Target
who's the brand oh yeah it used to be
Mossimo and I think it's good fellow or
something about Long Fellow Deeds
um
uh this one's crazy I don't know if we
talked about it yet I remember reading
this was from Kristen ever weighed out
at the bottom of a water slide at a
hotel for the day so you can use your
goggles to find the change that fell out
of everybody's pocket what the [ __ ] yeah
how nuts is that what are you a 98 year
old man out there one of those things
yeah that's [ __ ] that's worse than a
metal detector that has to be a kid
activity that's not an adult I guess
yeah how would you have the money to get
into a hotel if you were doing that kind
of sure I mean no yeah no that's a as a
kid it's for sure as a kid but like as a
kid you're like oh let me go see what
[ __ ] you know coins I can pull up and
that's pretty smart to be hanging at the
bottom of the water slide yeah where it
all flushes out I'll give you that but
it's trashy it's very trashy
um I've never done that as a kid but I
mean we've this has been well documented
in the Summers
you know you routinely went through
everybody's pockets in the closet every
coat pocket to find some kind of change
yeah yeah I remember one time I hit
[ __ ] pay there dude I mean it was
like it was like 80 bucks or something
what yeah the piece had like a couple of
the piece is real flustered when she's
checking out at the Super Fresh Fest so
it'll be like 20s and she'll [ __ ] in
the coat pocket or something you ever
get pinched
where's that money that was in my pocket
oh no this wasn't like July and it was a
coach [ __ ] December wow so you know
no body no crying you know what I mean
that's fantastic yeah dude I remember
the one day I was then like I was a
laffy taffy used to be purchased with 80
Beams I was looking for like five bucks
or something to go like just
skateboarding or like get your head on
straight just a [ __ ] you know make
right with the sharks
kick the big down the road just to have
a couple uh you know be able to get some
snacks or something with them [ __ ]
Deli while I'm [ __ ] hanging with the
boys uh maybe a slice is odd out there
when you weren't flush for snacks and
everyone was grubbing that was a tough
look yeah we were always real good
though because at some point every like
take care of each other my boy Pat was
constantly flush yeah because he would
live with his grandma was always around
so she would always break them off with
like a dub wow like here's a 20 and
that's 20 as a 10 year old forget it you
know kidding me so [ __ ] buy your own
hotel I remember the one time my mom was
still I was sitting there with my mom
and my boy Pat we were in college
probably like just turned 21 maybe even
before 21 and I'm like Mom we were so
like bro college kids like home for like
Christmas bro something thanks whatever
we're both home for the weekend and we
weren't working I was like Mom give us
give me some money so we can go drinking
and she's like I'm not just giving you
money she's like there's beer here like
drink here like I'm not giving you 50
bucks so you guys can go drink it at the
[ __ ] Pub all night okay so then same
thing with Pat's parents like we're not
just [ __ ] giving you money you guys
have been like take the night off or
whatever
so then Pat's Grandmom sent him a text
hey patch you know I stopped by the
house you weren't there I left 80 bucks
for you on the counter Pat thanks we got
80 bucks let's go I was like you're
gonna spend you're gonna split the money
with Kevin that your grandmother gave
you he's like hell yeah we are yeah
unless you're part of the solution shut
the [ __ ] up I got [ __ ] car bombs to
do
ah man
that was always big
um all right this one this is an
abbreviated one this is from Jesse ever
burn your eyebrows off because if you
are you're probably doing something you
shouldn't be doing 100 doing what not
all the way off but I singed them yeah
yeah lighting a Bernie uh or something
else yeah yeah crack pipe
um the big thing especially when you had
lighters as a kid you'd burn your legs
you ever like burn your leg hair oh yeah
yeah that smells oh man it's gross and
then I I drove for a laser hair removal
service for a long time and they would
do it in like a regular doctor's office
and after eight hours of [ __ ] cooking
Italian ladies [ __ ] legs Long Island
dude you'd walk in there it would hit
you like a [ __ ] two by four and I'd
say the technician like how the [ __ ] can
you stay in here okay they get used to
it burning hair nasty
um the other big thing as a kid with a
lighter would be burn your sock and it
would [ __ ] ever do that and it would
like wrap around your foot it would just
burn all like the the very fine hairs
that you like fibers that you can't see
on your sock should we do it no
uh I have brand new socks I don't know
if it would work uh there's like I go up
in flames
like the Olympic torch
um and like the hand the fibers you
can't see and if it's like a blue flame
would run around your foot and then go
out right away it's a good time it's a
fun time yeah it's not too shabby it's
about two notches underneath the fun of
lighting a fart on fire letting a fart
I've never done it oh my buddy Kramer
used to do it all the time classic
classic really what we were Elaine in
George show stopper
show stop what age were we talking here
a couple weeks ago
I don't know [ __ ] seventh eighth
grade okay I wasn't sure if you're doing
in high school like hey ladies you know
might have been
nice
I don't know why they left
um all right this one's from Joe your
mom ever played Candy Crush mine is
hooked the diesel Birds and the phone
embarrassing it's a they're addicted she
plays something I don't know what she
does it ain't Candy Crush but yeah
they're always doing something remember
I'm still playing Candy Crush no not
mine he was saying my mom is hooked oh
man either he's still pushing that
um yeah it's a tough [ __ ] look it
always made me want candy though
hard case not only I've ever played
Candy Crush
I've never been big on games in general
video games weren't my stees last system
I had was a PlayStation 2 and I got so
mad that I broke it
and then that was the last one I got a
little bit of an anger issue real cool
kid huh remember I broke my sister's
laptop too she was home from college why
because I was playing a game and I lost
and I [ __ ] took the screen and
snapped it really yeah I assume that
caused some I Then I then slid it under
the couch and like kind of put like a
half a blanket over it to try to be like
oh someone stepped on it or something
did it work I don't think so she was
like what are you like and this was like
this was like an IBM this was I mean she
went to college like she's like a little
bit younger than you right it's crazy
you're older than my sister that's nuts
um
she uh uh I guess she's 40. maybe
um she had like one of those big black
like you know it came with like the bat
like you know what I mean it was like
you were calling it an airstrike it had
that little little the red ball the red
those things were great a real [ __ ]
tactical with that you were playing
solitaire
I didn't get the waterfall I can't
[ __ ] beat this guy
it was great when the water the
waterfall but the cards would happen but
you watch that for a couple hours
[Music]
yeah
my dad taught me hey you need like eight
tables
it's like you're you need a picnic there
it's like you're an architect it's
[ __ ] rolling up rolling out the
drawings [ __ ] putting them here
putting the [ __ ] get out of here
holy [ __ ] yeah
that was always big like launching a
controller too was [ __ ] I don't I never
played I never had any of the wireless
do you remember those psycho kids I
always thought those kids were that was
stupid what
it's more anger I'm not like dude I used
to lose to my brother on purpose because
he would hit me with a controller if I
beat him oh the yikes way to keep it
cool psychos
holy [ __ ] let's get a sleepover together
huh yeah all right this guy's putting on
first down I wonder why you guys were
homeschooled you were probably kicked
out
a couple of animals that would have done
better uh I did not for the record it
did not for the record it did not this
one from Adam shout out to Adam shout
out to him uh we might have talked about
this at one point ever wiped nose grease
on the top of your beer to get rid of
the foam 100 yeah I remember when that
was shown to me I was like holy [ __ ]
that's gross but it worked it's more of
like a function especially when you're
playing beer pong and you gotta [ __ ]
or you're playing like a drinking game
and you gotta like you gotta kill the
foam quick
throw that in there now
take that one step further uh-huh have
you ever witnessed your server do that
as they were bringing your drink what
yeah you've seen that I've seen that
you've done that I have not okay where
you were you sitting were you at were
you uh were you a patron or were you
also working I was a patron at a
restaurant and the bar was right in
front of us and I saw a server do that
to somebody's drink and then bring it
over to their table it wasn't our table
what the [ __ ] yeah I'll take the can
please
cause the canned hamburger [ __ ] that
that's [ __ ] up
oh man I I was just somewhere yeah this
was probably 15 years ago sure yeah yeah
I think
I think they were still smoking in the
restaurant because more than 15 years
ago uh yeah it was probably 15 years
yeah yeah 15 16. I was in college when
they banned that that no more no more
Bernie's inside I mean dude that was
brutal I remember like I
was working at Martell's on the Upper
East Side in like I don't know 2000 2001
and
small little restaurant and I'm
literally having a Bernie at the bar
sure and then we'll just put it in the
ashtray and walk over you guys ready to
order yeah yeah that's another thing too
of I think uh so two stories one I have
to stop eating at a uh
uh bodegas like ordering like a sandwich
and stuff you do I did I just the one in
my neighborhood just the guys played a
little too fast and loose
um with the cleanliness yeah especially
going there late at night you know what
I mean if you get back from like a spot
or whatever and it's midnight you're
like I'll pop in and get a sandwich it's
like did I ask for a chicken parm and
they [ __ ] just did like the they get
like the chicken cutlet like the breaded
already they just gotta deep fry it then
they [ __ ] you know I'm listening they
put it on the griddle the sauce the
cheese cover it up it's easy peasy
what's the problem guy so I'm sitting
there only guy in there then guy comes
in he's like let me get a a chopped
cheese or whatever
I think he takes the hamburger the raw
hamburgers and chops it up
and then like I'm like dude and I'm
sitting there watching if I didn't see
it I wouldn't have mattered but I saw
I'm like dude don't just immediately go
scoop up my thing with that [ __ ] with
the wrong you can see the raw meat on
the [ __ ] on the [ __ ] spatulas
and I'm like don't do it man and he just
goes over Scoops it off right on the
[ __ ] bun I walked outside threw it in
the trash I said and I can't do it okay
I just can't and also I don't have the
tools to be like don't make me a new one
yeah like I'm just like I just go now
I'm done eating there but now also you
walk in there and they're eating like
what can I get you buddy I'm like what
the [ __ ] I don't know what are you
having what do you recommend Jesus yeah
I got like white sauce on their face I'm
like nah dude I'm out I'm done dude I
can't do it my Bodega I went and I asked
for an Italian hero they gave me a
chicken pesto Panini
yeah some of them just play by their own
rules they don't give a [ __ ] dude they
don't give a [ __ ]
but also I was at a I was at a diner
last week you know writing some jokes
having a [ __ ] omelet killing some
time and uh I go yeah can I get another
Diet Coke he comes over
he comes over I was like I had a Diet
Coke
sitting there right he comes over I go
okay another diet cookie goes yeah sure
and grabs it like this with his finger
in the [ __ ] cup well that's what I
was go reef and I'm like I watched him
I'm like if he gets me a new cop like if
he's busting the table like this that's
one thing but if he refills his cup and
his [ __ ] finger was just in did he
refill it yes did you drink captain
lemon what dip the lemon no [ __ ]
weight that's why I asked you do you
know anybody that drinks like this oh
that's disgusting yeah I do that a lot I
mean one thing if you're doing it I get
whatever it's your dirt you know refill
but like if a [ __ ] refill should be a
new glass I'd rather pay for it I I'll
yes if dude if you're trying give me a
nuke I want the fresh ice I want the
front the guy last night we're at the
diner in Jersey hey can I get a dog
another Diet Coke and I have like this
much left in mind and he just stands at
the table and waits for me to chug it
I'm like
what the [ __ ] just go get me a new glass
there's four people in this restaurant
you got the glasses yeah
oh [ __ ] that's good uh next meal though
it was pretty good uh okay sorry just
checking something real quick
um let's see this one's from Alexander
brand new patreon here first time
question have you or anyone your family
ever kept a BB gun by the bed to take
care of the squirrels in the Attic
jeez that's that's ever had Squirrels In
The Attic had skunks in the crawl space
that's close enough to squirrels in the
attic I feel
I had raccoons in the living room from
like 87 to 89 my house had a had a
pretty thick skunk smell I think we
might smell yeah now I didn't know it
was lingering we had a mothball a lot
mothball take care of it yeah they were
right right under the the front front
thing wow yeah tough look damn not at
the house you're in now yeah
we weren't going to war with the BB gun
though we did we had a groundhog problem
I couldn't shoot a squirrel
I shot a rabbit once and we felt so bad
about it we buried it had like a whole
we had like a full service sure lunch in
afterwards
proper rabbit burial I swear that we
felt never never picked up a firearm
again yeah I think I've mentioned I I
had BB guns all growing up mainly
because I think my mom would have let me
and I told my dad and he was like okay
what a [ __ ] strapping this kid's
gonna be Rambo so I had a bunch of them
and I shot a bird one time and killed it
and immediately felt bad oh it was one
of those things of like ah let me see if
I can get close or Scare him or what
like no intention of me thinking I was
gonna hit him Red Rider BB gun what was
it Eagle what'd you hit yeah bald eagle
um I told you it pulls right
uh killed one in the backyard tried to
hide it and then someone found it was
like what the [ __ ] is this what I don't
know how my stepmom I think
um he tried to hide it yeah it felt so
bad what are you in the gambinos
nobody no crime
I ripped his fingernails off
no I put it in like a brown bag and
threw it in the trash but my problem was
there was this nosy bro doing snooping
there was no other trash in the trash
can oh right it was like the outside
well I think she grabbed a brown paper
bag and there was a bird in it I think
she was like what this is clearly
something that I would have been in
therapy what after that that psycho kid
[ __ ] yeah she was like what hat and I
remember telling her I was like Hey
listen I didn't think I was gonna hit it
what happened yeah hey one thing led to
another we were arguing
yeah yeah yeah important thing is we
gotta get our story straight down first
things first I was never here
the birdcop show up I learned a lot
about kitties snapping laptops in half
he's going on murder sprees yeah fat
little weird kid what these were these
were old times what are you talking
about you get strep throat every year
this kid's a lemon
Jesus Christ get the extended warranty
on this one folks you're gonna need it
[ __ ] leaking oil oh [ __ ] I killed a
bird put it in brown paper big
hey that's not nice I don't know how you
would get up there that quick dude I
mean you got to be a pretty quick draw
where to if you to to wake up out of a
dead sleep grab the BB gun get the
ladder out get up well I think it's
maybe if you're what do you mean get the
ladder out an attic oh I'm assuming
you're shooting through the ceiling
that's what I'm taking I don't know or
if it's like trying to wall bang this
world I don't know listen it's not
suppressing fire what the [ __ ] hey cover
me I'm going to the bathroom
[ __ ] Saving Private chipmunk Jesus
Christ man
I don't think that's what he meant I I
don't know dude you're gonna wind up
with a bunch of [ __ ] Christmas
decorations with holes in them yeah how
are you gonna you can't shoot through a
drywall well that doesn't that doesn't
make sense to get a gun and then I'm
saying it might be like an open rafter
type situation I don't know that doesn't
make sense to get a BB gun this guy's
got squirrels in his house that's what
I'm doing they're not in the Attic
they're in the house yeah
they've taken the guest room
he wakes up ones on top of them with the
gun like Karen Hill yeah
what are you doing Karen I
my boys at Drexel had that squirrel
scratches just put down the guns
oh my God professor whiskers how you
gonna do me like this
you got me all wrong see
must be some kind of Dead Eye to shoot a
squirrel yeah well it could be using
Buckshot too who knows you know it could
be got a good spread on it
but y'all have a baby growing up you
know 12 game this is [ __ ] Anton segur
oh another another
uh another question that we've gotten a
handful of times I don't have the name
on it but I'm recalling it now have you
uh what do you know about or does
anybody have the uh salt guns
to kill flies the Bug Assault The Bug
Assault do you know that you you've
mentioned it to me oh I have yes oh okay
yeah uh and you for the break glass no
it's just like it's like [ __ ]
Buckshot but salt and it's supposed to
kill flies you keep it if you have flies
or like gnats or fruit flies or whatever
and either see it on the wall you just
[ __ ] and it you know it's awesome
yeah until the interior living room's
like a soft pretzel yeah it's all
[ __ ] over there it's like a Super
Pretzel Toby order three of those oh
that'd be extra ammunition yeah and some
goggles I'm using Himalayan sea salt
good stuff shooting pink missed that
yeah
I use rock salt
yikes trashy garbaggio my friend that
was the thing as a kid growing up in the
South you hear about some someone
getting shot in the ass of the rock salt
rock salt was big the farmers would have
it if you were there was always lures
because like where we grew up it was a
lot of Farmland when I was like very
young that all like you know that all
became uh was developed developed uh but
there was always like yeah they'll shoot
you know they'll [ __ ] come out if
you're [ __ ] around in the thing yeah
I said that about the cornfield behind
our house yeah I think they would that
old [ __ ] never made a move I knew
better yeah got the Quick Draw on them
um all right let's see this one's from
Thomas I believe it's from Facebook do
you have more key chains than keys
not a keychain guy at all I was never at
one point I think I had the bottle
opener and that was probably high school
college that's all I ever had for a
while I just had two loose keys that I
would carry around for the two not even
on a ring nah no ring didn't like it I
don't like the way it felt in my pocket
it was just two keys
that's like cat burglar [ __ ]
that's weird
like the thing and having all the Slim
Jims in there I don't think I wish I had
one of those that's real cool that
little thing that goes in and they put
the other one in and you flick on it no
way they're not you're all just lifting
the pins yeah no way though yeah
he's still working a locksmith no big
deal oh look at you yeah
hey a little locksmith did you work at
it was a lock and Vault did you make
keys yeah really Keys before I've pinned
locks where you take like a
you take like a lock like a you know
whatever just like the base of a lock
and then you like each pin has a
different like code or whatever and you
drop the pins to make it a unique key
okay yeah
you're the key maker I love the key
master really master of this I've always
wanted to use one of those things I
didn't know how to do that the guys that
I worked with could obviously oh you
couldn't work the key thing what do you
mean you're telling me you were dropping
pins but you couldn't make keys no no
made keys I'm saying I couldn't break a
I couldn't [ __ ] use the scalpel and
the [ __ ] no no I meant I meant the
key maker thing the thing that looks
like a sewing machine of course I've
made that I've made thousands of keys
wow that's pretty cool I'm a pretty cool
guy as a kid that was like meeting an
astronaut yeah that guy it's probably
some drunk but it was me
big-headed [ __ ] 21 year old I don't
even think I was I was 20 yeah I was 20
years old really yeah and I remember the
it was a safe company and they got real
[ __ ] pissed because on YouTube it
went viral uh some like Thief like you
know like lock breaking guy uh had a
YouTube channel or he would just break
into like all these like safes and stuff
and we had like this unbreakable safe
and he broke into it in like four
minutes on YouTube really yeah they were
real pissed at least they got into the
zx400 that's pretty sweet yeah I've seen
those videos where the people know the
the different sequences to push for soda
machines and stuff like that I think
that's all kind of fake no it is uh do
you know anything of that like each one
has a secret code yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've done it is that real it is but what
they it won't dispense for a while you
could get it to dispense but they fixed
that [ __ ] real quick did they uh you
know what I'm still impressed by but you
can you can like open the menus and like
change [ __ ] and stuff so much for free
sodas
you know what I'm really impressed by uh
then machine technology to the point
where they have them at the airports I
don't that's the only time I really use
a vending machine is at the airport
after we land or a hotel or a hotel but
hotels don't have it airports for other
places I've been in the I've been in
this in a vending machine I've been in
the the snack slash ice room with you
many a late night oh yeah
big fan of like some cheese it's some
pretzel some that absorbed all the booze
rolling all the ipas floating around the
screamer
um cold Gatorade uh but they uh the
thing that zips up and meets it in the
middle that like then instead of
dropping oh that's like AI technology
dude that I there's
dude there's one at [ __ ] there's one
at the what the baggage terminal of
every airport whenever we're waiting I
always get like a [ __ ] drink and that
thing I sit there in amazement of how
that thing works that's like from iRobot
type [ __ ] yeah dog when that thing first
dropped there was a hack where if you
put your hand on the door that it's
supposed to slide through it'll slide
it'll hit it it'll think it didn't
dispense the soda it'll give you a
second soda for free
again T-Bone he probably has slugs for
the subway too this guy okay you Chicago
kids man you guys you guys are out there
huh wild hey who wants a free barks huh
running
aiming his boys on a Friday night yeah
they'll get you huh six pack of soda hey
fellas
get you uh
uh let's see this is a first time
question this is from Mike we've talked
about this have you ever purchased food
in like a strip mall I like the pizza
place and then your buddies were eating
at the chicken place and he took the
pizza to the chicken place like taking
outside food into a place trash I've
never done it I've had buddies that done
it and I can't do it you're a dirt ball
if you do it and then don't give the
[ __ ] server and Addison well they're
eating shut the [ __ ] up yeah yeah it's
like get the [ __ ] out [ __ ] yeah
that's that's no [ __ ] Bueno kids is a
difference outdoor food you can't do
kids different situation but clean that
you bring the crackers or something
clean that [ __ ] up under the [ __ ]
high chair yeah okay especially if
you're a 15 percenter
all right yeah I'm not [ __ ] cleaning
up [ __ ] egg noodles and [ __ ]
mushed up string beans from your little
kid
now if you order some chicky fingers for
them like a gentlemen he don't finish
them I'll take care of that
so you can do 15 all day yeah
yeah it's a thin line though sure with
eating off kids plates they're real
gross I would never but they don't
finish anything sure you know it's tough
yeah I don't even like you know if my
nephews and stuff like I'll if they drop
the nuggets real quick I'll snag one no
I'll tell you what those two I Don't Go
Near them
but they net literally like whole
hamburgers
but you just know there's you know even
as gross design yeah it's all boogered
yeah it's a booger force field
no I'm telling you I was just home last
weekend or whatever uh went home had
like dinner at the house on Sunday with
the old nieces nephews Brothers sister
the whole nine everybody was there and
for the kids they came out with the
chicken nuggets like but they put in
like one you know two boxes like the
Weavers or whatever they came out and
dropped those things crispy Brown dude
uncle uncle Kev was all over that stuff
talking one from each plate fantastic
all right let's wrap it up gang we love
you uh it's been a family episode we
will uh can we got anything for him uh
just at Kevin rank comedy on all social
media let's get those numbers up follow
are you garbage follow uh on Twitter
also too uh if you're I guess you should
uh there's a Discord for the patreon
members uh that there we just
established a new admin or something
they're trying to get that boom in so
check out the Discord if you're on the
patreon very nice and don't forget come
see us Gotham Comedy Club Gothic Gotham
Comedy Club New York City November it's
gonna sell out we said that about Philly
and guess what it sold the [ __ ] out it
sold out do it we love you come see us
we love you bye